[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
hôpital sortir des urgences depuis deux
ans les infirmiers et aides soignants
qui ont quitté l'hopital public se
comptent par milliers
conscient du malaise des soignants le
sénat a créé en janvier dernier une
commission d' enquête sur la situation
de l'hôpital et le système de santé en
france dont bernard jomier était le
président et catherine de roche la
rapporteure
en guise de remède les sénateurs
prescrivent à l'hôpital public des
moyens proportionnés aux défis de santé
actuel ainsi que davantage de liberté et
d'autonomie dans son organisation
dans son rapport publié le 31 mars 2022
la commission souligne l'engagement des
personnels de l'hôpital
elle souhaite que l'attractivité de leur
métier soit garanti
le ségur de la santé a conduit à des
revalorisations salariales
mais celles ci sont apparus comme trop
tardives et mal définie
par exemple les heures supplémentaires
et le temps de travail additionnelle
doivent être mieux pris en compte et
encadré
la sénatrice auteurs du rapport alerte
aussi sur les conditions de travail
dégradées qui génère une désaffection
préoccupante à l'égard de l'hôpital
face au sentiment de perte de sens il
convient de renforcer la qualité de vie
au travail des soignants et leur
permettre ainsi de se concentrer sur le
soin
pour cela la commission denquête appelle
à un renforcement conséquent des
effectifs d'infirmiers et
d'aides-soignants
elle préconise aussi le développement
d'outils numériques plus performant le
recours à des applications intelligentes
et la délégation de certaines tâches aux
secrétaires médicaux et aux techniciens
si le nombre de postes vacants et le
taux de rotation des personnels augmente
c'est aussi en raison du manque de
perspectives de carrière dans les
hôpitaux
c'est pourquoi la commission appelle à
repenser les carrières hospitalières
notamment en concevant de nouvelles
passerelles entre les professions
le deuxième axe du rapport porte sur la
gouvernance et le financement de
l'hôpital
la commission denquête fait valoir la
pertinence d'un pilotage médico
administratifs équilibré de l'hôpital
avec une décentralisation des décisions
elle appelle parallèlement à une refonte
du modèle de financement de l'hôpital
public
enfin la commission propose plusieurs
solutions pour fluidifier le système de
soins et désengorger l'hôpital
il faudrait par exemple revaloriser la
médecine générale approfondir la
coordination entre la ville et l'hôpital
pour soulager les services d'urgence et
améliorer la structuration de l'offre de
proximité
pour en savoir plus consultez le rapport
de la commission d' enquête
[Musique]